[MUSIC PLAYING]
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Hi, I'm Magnus
Hyttsten for the Developers
Show, and we are here at
the TensorFlow Dev Summit.
And I'm standing here
with Chris Lattner.
Hello, Chris.
CHRIS LATTNER: Hi, Magnus.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: So
Chris, you are actually
one of the original founders
of the Swift language.
Is that correct?
CHRIS LATTNER: That's true.
It started as a nights
and weekends project,
and it grew to something a
little bit bigger than that.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: That's
absolutely amazing.
And you just had a talk
on TensorFlow and Swift
that may be surprising
to some people.
How does these two things--
how did they get together?
CHRIS LATTNER:
Well, it turns out
that Swift has some really
interesting capabilities
that most other
languages don't have.
And so one of the neat
things about Swift
is it was designed
from the very beginning
with the idea of spanning
all the way from systems
programming all the way
up to scripting languages.
And it turns out that
TensorFlow is really
a sweet spot for
that, because you
want to be able to program
TensorFlow like a scripting
language and be able to use
high-level abstractions,
but you also care about
low-level performance as well.
And so Swift is really
well-positioned to fit that.
Beyond that, Swift
is a great language
because it supports the
kind of compiler analysis
and all the deep
internal stuff that
makes it possible to
do what we're doing
with Swift for TensorFlow.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: And it's very
modern in syntax, compact,
and it has the construct
that you would expect?
CHRIS LATTNER: Absolutely.
So Swift was starting
in 2010, so it's not
that old by language standards.
And so one of the great
things about that is it
gets to build on all the best
things that have been learned,
that are modern techniques
in programming languages.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Super cool.
So I think most people--
or you developers
out there-- that you associate
Swift with iOS development.
But this has nothing to do
with iOS development, correct?
CHRIS LATTNER: Absolutely.
Swift is an open
source language,
and people use it for
server development
and a lot of other things
that are beyond iOS as well.
And so this is just a great way
to express tensor computations
and be able to build your
machine learning algorithms
in a natural way
where the compiler can
help you write your code.
It can detect errors for you.
It can make your life
better so that you
can focus on getting
the job done instead
of trying to fight
through the framework
and trying to deal
with typical problems.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Super cool.
So I guess the question
on everyone's mind
is how can I get
involved in this?
How can I use Swift
with TensorFlow?
CHRIS LATTNER: Oh,
that's really easy.
So it's still a very
early stage project,
but we're opening our
open source project
in the next month.
So in the month of
April, you can sign up.
At that time, we're
publishing not just the code,
but also white papers.
And we're also allowing
open development,
so you too can contribute
to the project.
And so if you're
interested in that,
you can go to tensorflow.org/c
ommunities/swift.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Super cool.
So it's going to be
really interesting to see
what you developers create
with Swift and TensorFlow.
I'm Magnus Hyttsten.
This is Chris Lattner.
We're at the TensorFlow Dev
Summit for Developers Show.
[MUSIC PLAYING]